breaking news again on Russia after last
night's attempt to stop the devaluation
of the rubble it hasn't worked and right
now we go through an historic level 70
on dollar uh Rubble the chart is simple
it's a three-day chart we've seen one
two three and now four failures through
the series is just outside this wck
rectangle which sort of was my target 10
minutes ago and we've blown through that
as we move ever higher the ramifications
of this ticket by tick for the Russian
Financial system uh can can barely be
mentioned and Vladimir Putin just Aid
seven years in the last 10 minutes well
you wonder where we are we get a speech
from Putin before we get to 10: a.m. us
does he impose Capital controls before
his state of the nation address Dennis
what it makes me wonder is that you know
this this move by the Russian Central
Bank you know what if it had the the
opposite of its intended effect it sing
it signaled panic